[Music]
being a kid in the 90s men spending most
of your quarters trying to beat your
friends in Street Fighter the gaming
community was filled with memorable
players but one kid seemed to eclipse
them all the legendary tummo Ohira one
of the greatest video game players who
ever lived
[Music]
tamal Hira
was this towering figure in Street
Fighter 2
guy that legendary that's kind of guy
you want to aspire to be so why did the
champion disappear in 1991 arcades went
through a renaissance with the release
of Street Fighter 2 the game
re-energized the coin op business
drawing people away from their home
consoles and back to the air cave up
until then arcade winners were
determined by the highest score but with
Street Fighter 2 players dueled each
other in one-on-one competitions the
fierce matches and cutthroat rivalries
made the game into a bona fide sporting
event turning champions into legends and
a group of all-stars was forming in
sun-baked Southern California to get
this story started we first need to
understand that Street Fighter is a lot
more than a bunch of button mashing and
who better to explain the complexities
of the game then legendary players Jeff
Shafer and Mike Watson what Street
Fighter is really is a chess game they
have six different buttons that you can
push and whether you're standing or
crouching the buns are different and so
you have so much diversity of different
punches and kicks in a fighting game
each character has their own specific
moves those specific moves can be used
in combinations so there's so many
different variations available in the
game based on whatever character I'm
playing I know what distance that
character is weak at so it's all about
forming your game plan around staying at
that distance to win the game this is
the bread and butter of becoming
exceptional at any game that's Street
Fighter and if you haven't guessed it
yet Mike and Jeff are really good at
Street Fighter 2
I became the best player in Orange
County and then eventually I got banned
from playing because it was a foregone
conclusion that I was gonna win
I would beat everybody there was no one
I ran into that I didn't beat you know I
was a little kid just shooting my mouth
off all the time but that was part of my
strategy actually we always played to
win the whole crowd was thinking like
wow Jeff's on his own level you know no
one could touch me
I was eating everybody for lunch and
that's when I met Tim O'Hara he was
about 13 years old probably weighed
about 90 pounds and was 5 feet tall and
he was just so like a kid he's a smaller
guy so it wasn't intimidating anything
but man he played lights-out no mistakes
it's just his play just amazing he's a
gaming savant
you know I must have spent over $20 in
quarters to beat him one game and I
never beat in one game I can't win one
game off the guy he's very much like
Michael Jordan or Tiger Woods they don't
need to talk crap they already know
they're the best he was hands down the
number one player at the time I was kind
of dumbfounded by it
it was like tolmol me Jeff and then
fourth place is way down here and in
1994 the three participated in a super
tournament to find out who was the best
player of all time
there was a big super tournament in
NorCal that all of us went to it was
like the biggest battle royale ever in
the history of Street Fighter at that
time we're finally gonna find out right
in Southern California better than this
group here
it was literally shoulder-to-shoulder
people packed in like sardines and you
can probably guess what happened Tomo
won at all but then something unexpected
happened
the world's best Street Fighter 2 player
completely disappeared
he just quit that was it
he never played street fighter again
after that
I felt a little empty I guess he was my
competition he was always the one that
would beat me he just finally walked off
into the sunset questions haunted the
gaming community where is Tomo where is
the champion everybody asked about him
for years
his name rung out through the arcades in
Southern California everyone wanted to
find Toma LAN play against him but they
never got that opportunity
the original gaming savant was gone so
at this point you're probably asking
yourself what became of the legendary
Tomo Hira this is my life now getting
balls out of the tree for the neighbors
kids my name is Tomo Akira I used to
play street fighter a long long time ago
I was known as the first champion a
street fighter and the feeling was just
incredible I think people were a little
bit surprised by me leaving kind of
suddenly because I had such a passion
for it but eventually it went from yes I
want oh my god I can't believe it too
okay good
I didn't I didn't lose today so now that
I have to be upset tonight and that's
when I fell out of it
when we became adults right you don't
have the eight hours a day to put into
becoming like he was when he was a kid
he accomplished what he wanted he left
on top and we played one final turn him
in and he won so he kind of walked out
on a high note when something is done I
think he should realize it face it and
let it go so now my passion is family I
have twin kids that are two years old
and as soon as they're old enough I will
hand them a gaming pad and see what they
can do you say I win that's my life now
and if I had to turn the clock back and
do it all over again I would not change
a thing
[Music]
you
you